growing questions over how the fbi
handled two politically explosive
stories a few hours ago the doj released
the heavily redacted affidavit that was
used to justify the raid and show
probable cause for that raid at
mar-a-lago
a look at some of it
what do you think you know
what do you think um we didn't get much
page after page of black bars failing to
ease the american public's concerns
about why the fbi felt it was necessary
to search the former president's home it
comes as we also get new details on how
the fbi handled another very
consequential case meta ceo mark
zuckerberg admitting to joe rogan that
facebook censored the infamous hunter
biden laptop story weeks before the 2020
election because the fbi came to them
and said
you are about to get some russian
disinformation watch this
the fbi i think basically came to us
some folks on our team it was like hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was
we we thought there was a lot of russian
propaganda in the 2016 election we have
it on notice that basically there's
about to be some kind of dump of of um
uh
that's similar to that so just be
vigilant i think it was
five or seven days when it was basically
being
um
being determined whether it was false
um the distribution on facebook was
decreased but people were still allowed
to share it so you could still share it
you could still consume it
okay um janine i actually want to ask
you about the first part of that story
about the affidavit
i talked to andy mccarthy and brett
tolman today both former u.s attorneys
they said the more they looked at it
and the parts that you could see because
there was a lot that you could get your
hands around a little bit
they said they don't see any criminal
prosecution coming in this even though
there was a grand jury subpoenaed in
order to do this
it's not unusual for a prosecutor to use
a grand jury and a grand jury subpoena
to get information with no intention of
getting an indictment and you usually
get a an affidavit
and i know these are unusual
circumstances at are about the time that
the indictment is announced that's when
you start learning about what the
affiant was using as a basis for
probable cause
i looked at this also obviously and i
must tell you what what i there there's
so much in here that's striking we don't
have enough time but if you recall they
when this first started we heard about
espionage the fbi leaking oh it's about
espionage there's terrible things going
on kim jong-un well so much of this is
blacked out but i got to tell you
there's nothing in here that i can see
that relates to espionage however
it seems that this is ultimately a
question of whether or not the president
has the right to declassify and whether
or not presidential records are personal
or part of the national archives and you
know the case law is pretty clear it's
personal uh but what what is even more
interesting to me is the second
paragraph where it says after an initial
review of the narrow referral with the
national archives group the to the fbi
they opened a criminal investigation to
among other things to determine how many
documents uh with classification
markings were removed so they're already
in there removing 15 boxes and then they
make a they make a request to the fbi to
start a criminal investigation wait a
minute you were just in there getting
boxes the president stopped by he said
hello you told him to double padlock it
when you go back to new york because
everybody knows or new jersey he comes
back in the summertime it the all of
this stuff coming together and you know
obstruction you can't you can't have
obstruction of something that's not a
crime
i i'll tell you i agree if that's what
if that's what mccarthy and brett tolman
said i agree i don't think there's
anything coming out of that and i think
it's just classic
it's the fbi trashing and the more the
fbi does this the more they leak this
kind of information the more this place
is an institution is going to lose
respect i do want to say one thing about
zuckerberg yeah this guy needs to be
placed under oath i want to know who he
talked to what exactly they told him
whether or not they mentioned 51 of
these intelligence officers which i seem
to recall reading somewhere which tells
me they knew it was coming they had it
for a long time and they wanted to
suppress this information with these
so-called 51 intel officers none of whom
have said oh gee we were wrong and it
wasn't russian disinformation that is
his oppression of free speech and by the
way he said you could you could exchange
this information bologna you couldn't
find it to exchange it if you looked
under a rock you might find hunter biden
and the difference between there
treating this president and ex-president
of the united states and a drug addict
who's sucking money all over the world
is shocking
richard
you want to respond
i'll start where we agree
so i agree with you i do think that they
need to put um mr zuckerberg under oath
one being i don't think you can think
the fbi comes to visit you like i think
you know when the fbi shows up at your
company right
and so i think he should put under oath
i think there's a larger conversation
that we need to have around how we deal
with social media platforms and whether
we need to repeal 230 or what a new 230
looks like even the social media
platforms are asking for reforms at 2
30. so i'll put that there um and i also
remind folks that hunter biden is still
under an active investigation joe biden
had the ability to fire the u.s attorney
that was involved in that case he did
not and so hunter biden continues to be
under an fbi and justice department
investigation now on to this redacted
document now i was one of those people
who called for it to be out i'm happy
that it is out unfortunately there's not
enough information for us to ascertain
exactly why this probable cause warrant
was fully given i think what we do know
from this document and what we also know
from trump's team himself is that the
first collection they had 100 classified
documents based on this doc based on
this they had an additional 92 documents
mark classified another 25 documents
marked top secret and more documents
after that now my question is and i
think based on my reading of the law i'm
not a lawyer but based on my reading law
and talking to the folks that i talked
to from my reporting most there's a
process when you declassify you just
don't wake up one morning and say just
declassify everything there's a process
in which you go through the liaison to
the national archives at the white house
and you work on declassifying these
documents i'm not sure that the former
president did that and as a result of
that every american should wonder what
documents wrap mar-a-lago and what's at
risk are some of our spies at risk or
some of our assets in the field at risk
are some of our nuclear secrets at risk
because we actually don't know what's in
this document so we have to wait to see
and i think we should not speculate on
two and if that were the case i mean you
know we're all just we don't know what's
under those black lines right but don't
you think if that were the case that
they would be moving towards a criminal
prosecution
what was this raid all about because
you've got a person who may run for
president again under investigation by
the department of justice by the person
he might be running against so you
better you better be damn sure when you
go in there that you you've got some
pretty serious
issues that you're not just going in
there to make a big scene and then have
everybody pull little pieces out of
things that are under black marks for
months and months and months and months
right and give this material out there
to be picked apart and leaked
selectively by the justice department if
you don't if you don't have your ducks
in a row martha better be you know
i agree with you but what we thought
what we know from a document that was
released by trump's lawyers himself on
june 1st they indicated they have no
more classified documents and when the
fbi went there they found 92 documents
there are a lot of people that take
issue with your characterization of the
president what the president can or
can't do as far as i'm talking about
what the law says as far as
classification well the law changed
under obama and george w bush
a lot more latitude that presidents have
and there's and there's a lot of uh it's
fair there's some disagreement about
that i guess what you might say the
visit of the fbi was a semi visit uh
that mark zuckerberg was uh like
semi-fascism a semi-ray to semi-visit
these two stories next to each other
tell a damning story of the fbi so you
have fbi agents whistleblowers came to
senator johnson and said we were told
not to investigate hunter biden's laptop
we were told not to do that yet they
were willing to go to facebook and say
yeah there's this information that's
about to come out and you should
classify it as russian disinformation
and then facebook does it and then on
the other side are we really having a
fight about documents here is this is
this what we're shaking up these doctors
we're going to get we're going to get
president trump because he had a love
letter from kim jong-un
everybody watching this feels like all
those redactions are more evidence that
this was a fishing expedition from the
beginning an opportunity to get into his
home as an opportunity to find other
crimes if they could out of sheer
desperation to crush a political
opponent who if he runs in 2024 now
knows how washington works which is why
the establishment is even more scared of
them and that's why this affidavit being
exposed doesn't solve anything and by
the way i gotta say one thing they
didn't say why they went in melania's
closet
no i might i think a lot more
you know i mean i hope we'll eventually
learn what's under some of those black
marks but one of the things that strikes
me cat is the two-year investigation
that was launched on the back of in part
a a p-tape that was salacious that no
one ever saw okay then you've got the
laptop which by the way hunter never
said it wasn't his nobody's ever denied
that
and and everyone's seen it all across
the country and this is someone who is
doing business with with china with
ukraine so there's a lot more there
there here but they were told like oh
yeah don't talk about that and i think
that is a massive story and i think
that's a story that everybody should
care about uh even if you're somebody
who you're the biggest biden supporter
in the whole world you should still care
because the fbi is not supposed to be
using its power for political purposes
the same with republicans you shouldn't
only care because you support trump or
you don't support biden there is pete as
you brought up there are a lot of
reasons to suggest that take trump out
of it take the hole right out of it for
a second that the fbi has a level of
power that it's using in a political for
political purposes and that should
bother everybody as americans because we
all are supposed to have fourth
amendment protections yeah and they
should be bending over backwards given
what's happened over the last few years
to make sure that people have confidence
in them in every way so you don't pull
up a raid like this unless you're short
now and you know we'll say it again this
story is not over right we're gonna
learn a lot more you know they could
treat donald trump the way they treated
hillary clinton when she deleted 33 000
emails and they sent her a subpoena but
they'd send a subpoena and she and then
she would please finish but if the
president declassified these documents
so you say that the president should be
able to release them to the american
people excuse me we already know that
other countries tried to hack into her
classified information on her phone
all right we got to leave it there i
went to brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now